this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro cover by eight sleep it's
the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users
fall asleep up to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
percent and get more restful sleep
overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get two hundred
and fifty dollars off of the pod pro
cover that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim
or use code tim that's eight all spelled
out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m-eight sleep dot com slash tim
for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by tonal
that's t-o-n-a-l
tonal is the world's most intelligent
home gym and personal trainer
that's the tagline from their website
folks so it gives you the one sentence
summary
by eliminating traditional metal weights
tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen
tv it mounts right on your wall with no
floor space required
i've had one for a few months now after
a number of close friends
recommended tonal to me and it allows me
to do things that i would normally need
a huge gym for
like cable chop and lift or rotational
exercises and it allows me to do other
things
that are nearly impossible otherwise
like eccentric loading which i'll talk
about again later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights
and ai learning together with the best
experts in resistance training so you
can get stronger
faster one of my friends who used to be
a competitive skier
very high level competitive skier has
doubled his strength in many exercises
over a period of months
so what are these adaptive digital
weights tonals patented digital weight
system makes thousands of calculations a
second to deliver you a smooth
weightlifting experience using their
advanced electronic motor technology
and a lot of the buttons are built right
into the handles themselves into the
grips
so you don't need to move around and it
is extremely easy
to use tonal lets you adjust the weight
in one pound increments and you can do
it on the fly
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down with just the touch
of a button
tonal also has built-in dynamic weight
modes like
chains eccentric and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains and bands
the eccentrics which i mentioned means
that you can
set a mode that allows you to say just
as an example bicep curl
15 pounds up and then lower
automatically 20
25 pounds down and it is incredible
how much you can get done in just a
handful of minutes
when you use this type of technology so
check it out
tritonal t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest
home gym for 30 days in your home and if
you don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.com
t-o-n-a-l dot com and for a limited time
get 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code
tim21 like i'm ready for
my first drink at checkout that's
www.tonaltonal.com
promo code tim 21 tim21
tonal be your strongest optimal minimum
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i ask you a personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to
interview world-class performers from
all different areas
and i feel very fortunate today to have
not only a world-class performer in his
own right but
a world-class performer who has a lot of
experience working
with world class performers george
mumford
he is a globally recognized speaker
teacher and coach
since 1989 he's been honing his gentle
but groundbreaking mindfulness
techniques with people from locker rooms
to board rooms from yale to jail while
at the university of massachusetts where
he roomed with future hall of famer
julius irving injuries forced mumford
out of basketball and eventually into an
addiction to pain medication and drugs
with the help of meditation and
mindfulness he got clean and made it his
mission
to teach and work with others michael
jordan credits george with transforming
his on-court leadership
helping the bulls to six nba
championships george has also worked
with kobe bryant shaquille o'neal
and countless other nba players as well
as olympians executives and artists
george believes everyone has a
masterpiece within his book
the mindful athlete secrets to pure
performance both memoir and instruction
guide can show you how to access it
george also has
the mindful athlete course which can be
found at georgemumford.com as well as
many other resources
you can find him on instagram at
george.mumford m-u-m-f-o-r-d
and on twitter at gt mumford
george welcome to the show thank you tim
it's a pleasure to be here i'm excited
about being here
me too we were introduced by our mutual
friend
jack cornfield who has nothing but
wonderful things
to say and you are a practitioner
in more ways than one so i love digging
into the details and the stories
so we're gonna start with a story and
then we'll probably rewind
but i would love to hear about the first
time
you ever watched michael jordan practice
what was that experience like the first
time i watched michael jordan practice
it was amazing
because he there's no difference between
how he plays and what he how he
practices so if you see him performing
on the court that's how he practices
there's no difference he just playing at
a high level playing the win
but also you can see how he gets better
each time he gets on the court he's just
really
locked in and really committed to
excellence i want to dovetail because my
first encounter with michael was not
in practice it was when i first went to
work with the bulls he had retired and
even though he was retired he wasn't
with the team
he actually was hanging around he was in
a locker room
and so i asked of one of the players or
might have been a coach that
introduced me to him even before i could
get close to him
i could feel his aura i could feel his
his ability
his level of concentration his mind
focus
his ability he had this energy and i'm
like an impact so i can feel things
i'm a feeler it was so profound even
before i even got to meet him just
feeling the energy that exuded from him
and his ability
to really be the eye of the hurricane in
the midst of things so
that was the first fascinating thing i
saw about him was just his energy
just walking into the room and meeting
him even though he didn't have one
basketball
uniform he wasn't out on the court he
was just in the locker room just hanging
out
what is it that you felt like in your
body
what was that experience like in
meditation circles we talk about getting
into a state of
intense state of concentration or
samadhi or calm so when you're really
concentrated
and you're really locked in there's a
like an alert relaxedness so you're
alert but there's a poise there because
you're in the moment you're centered
and you're just totally present and
that's what it felt like it just felt
like
there was an energy a calm energy but
also an intense energy
so that's what it felt like a
combination of intensity and calmness
now you can't trust everything you read
but i was of course doing some reading
in preparation for this so please feel
free to
fact check this but i read that when you
first saw him practicing
you thought to yourself something along
the lines of there's no way he can
sustain that this must be someone with
bipolar disorder
or some type of disorder who's in a
manic stage
is there any truth to that no i never
said that okay
so i never no because my thing is see i
i know the difference between
high intensity and having an intensity
based on
on a mindset that's positive and
combined
the one thing i did notice about the
first practice that you reminded me of
was that when i first saw him practice
he looked like a person trying to make
the team in what respect he was just
he was putting forth the extra effort
putting forth the extra effort like i
got to make the team and of course
now i understand why he was that way
because what he did was
let's think about how he related to his
experience we call it strong
self-efficacy
it's like when you master your mastery
of life experiences so he got cut from
his high school basketball team
in the 10th grade and so i think at that
time he made a decision he would never
get cut
from a team again and i saw that in the
practice
where he was acting like he was trying
to make the team now i don't mean like
like he has an anxiety and he's trying
to
impress people i'm saying he was
proven that he's the best player on the
court you were getting his best you were
getting
at a high level he wasn't resting he was
acting like
i need to get better i need to prove a
point not so much prove a point
but to let people know that there's no
way i'm not making this team
but there's no way i'm not going to be
central to what we're doing
so i see it as a positive i don't
remember saying that because i don't
know if i would
i would say he has high energy i know
other people have high energy
but his difference of him having high
energy it's with a purpose
and there's a cat-like quality to it
and what i mean by like a cat like
quality like you can see a cat a house
cat
they can go from being kind of chill to
jump into action
with a grace with the ease with the
ferocity and with the
direction like a direct assault or
whatever they just
he was like yeah he could punch on you
any minute
[Applause]
and we're gonna certainly come back to
michael jordan who
especially i mean at that time was
effectively treated like a god i mean
this was
this was the man who could walk on water
and
uh i'll add a footnote just for anyone
advice who's listening if so this is an
article from
vice.com which has a lot of great
articles well researched articles but
this one may need some factual
corrections so that is the zen
masters zen master which is a great
headline though you must admit
that is this very complimentary headline
let's roll back the clock because i
wanted to provide
a snapshot of
you working with not just
athletes at the top of their game but
really at the time
this pantheon of athletes who were
worshiped around the world and there's a
big difference
and there really is a difference right
but it wasn't always that way
far from it and so let's fact
check a separate quote and you can tell
me if this is
more on the money and i should say also
that the
manic quote wasn't so much a quote it
was an indirect quote so they didn't use
quotation marks but they said
to himself and things like that this is
one that i believe
is a direct quote it's from the boston
globe
quote i had a security clearance on my
badge and track marks on my forearm
if that is even approximately accurate
could you provide a time and a place
for when this was and explain please
yeah that was totally accurate
because when i first dropped out of
college
was i was working in what was called it
was a financial management development
program
and i was working for gte slovenia i
don't even know if that what they're
called now
but general telephone electronics and
then sylvania lightbulbs and
there was a big company at the time when
i got out of college
i was a functional addict
and so i had tracks on my arms so i had
i always wore long-sleeve shirts i
couldn't we
wear short sleeve shirts and this was
from heroin use
yeah from shooting up yes so in those
days when
when i was getting my security clearance
they literally had
fbi agents coming around and
interviewing my friends and family
going back 10 years you have to go
through this tremendous process just to
get a
secret clearance then it's top secret
but i had the secret clearance
so i had the clearance but at the same
time i had this hidden life
of you know tracks on my arm so that's
very accurate it's
totally accurate and it wasn't until
probably
when i got clean and 84 years after that
that there's no
no more track marks but for yes it was
very
tenuous because i was concerned about
passing physicals because i had to get
exempted by the doctors and they said oh
what's up with that you know
what's that on your arm you know they
kind of know what it looks like that was
a process
and as a matter of fact when i used to
have to give blood sometimes
they would make a comment like well you
got that all used up look
on your arms you know so i would just
laugh at it but it was a
fair statement so yeah i had to wear
long sleeve shirts all year round
at that time then this might seem like a
really silly question
because in the introduction and in the
bio i read
it mentioned injuries
and addiction but at that point when you
had this clearance
and you're shooting up
why were you an addict that's not to say
that it wasn't
natural and understandable i'm just i'm
just wondering if it was a byproduct of
the pain and then you became physically
dependent or if there was more to it
it's complex but one of the things i
discovered in my
days of competing as an athlete when i
got injured
they didn't have pain medicine so they
would give me
divemon or they'd give me some kind of
pain because i was always in pain
part of it was emotional pain i had a
lot of stomach problems or gi
issues because of stress i noticed that
when i was was under the influence of
these
pain meds that i actually felt good and
i could talk to people
other than that i was quiet and shy and
let my basketball talk to me so it
impacted me in a certain way
like any addiction so you do it you do
it and then you cross that line where
you become addicted you cannot not do it
not only does it become something that
your body craves but it becomes
part of a lifestyle part of an identity
so i got my
first vaccination shot two weeks ago
tomorrow and i remember so she went
right into my arm
gave me a vaccination spot and i
realized that it reminded me when i
started using drugs i didn't start off
just
going into the vein i started off what
we call skin popping just like getting
the vaccine
it is put into your system into the skin
so it always starts when you you know
you just get high a little bit
then it keeps growing it's a progressive
thing it's a progressive disease and it
kept progressing and then you start
doing other things and then you start
doing things in combination and then
you're doing drugs that are not even
your drugs of choice or drinking things
you don't even drink
you're looking to get high so it's the
emotional pain but it's also
a way of dealing with reality so that
was my thing
i was under influence in one way for
more fashion
many addicts don't make it out
or they don't stop using until they
either just continue as a functioning
addict
until the end of their days or
some catastrophe befalls them
what were the deciding moments
or elements that helped you to become
sober
i had an incident i think it was in
march
because i went to my first 12-step
meeting which was aaa
on april fools day april 1st in march
i had a strep infection
but i didn't know that i was sick until
i went to the doctors and i had a 104
degree temperature so i had to
go in the hospital i went in the
hospital and they had an abscess on my
arm and they had to
treat it and they wouldn't give me any
pain meds because they knew i was
addicted to drugs and i was withdrawing
or whatever
and at that point as people would say
you know if you keep this up you're
going to die and for some reason
it hit me that i just couldn't do it
anymore
and so i got to a spiritual bottom so i
call it it's the elevator
theory you might start off at the
penthouse
and for some people they have to go to
the sub-level b2 or b3 whatever it is
but for me i knew i was at maybe not at
the penthouse but if i was on
on the 25th floor i'm now on the fourth
floor then
i'm heading towards the third floor so
i decided to get out because you know i
just couldn't do it anymore it was just
emotionally it was like being in a place
where i couldn't do it anymore but i
could not
not do it because it was a habit that
was in march when i think started
hitting the rock bottom and then when my
friend came by
took me to a meeting on april 1st that's
when i saw that
there was there was a way forward there
was a way out i looked at
this person that was like me but yet he
was
yeah sobriety i went to the meeting and
then i continued to use
in but i started thinking about ways and
then when i went into the detox
i was different but i think all of that
paid dividends so even though i was
around recovery going to meetings
but i was still getting high and well
using drugs and alcohol but mostly
yeah i was doing both but it was
different something changed when i
shifted when i went to my first meeting
but then what happened when i
went into the detox there was a
thought process or inner dialogue just
said
the same george that goes in here can't
be the same george that comes out
because the same george that goes in if
that george comes out he's going to get
high he's going to keep doing what he's
doing
so you have to be a different person you
have to be a different george
and i don't know where that came from it
was just just the thought that told me
that yeah i had to do it differently i
had to be different
where were you at the time
geographically yeah i was living in
dorchester i mean
actually i lived in matapan so i was
living in boston
a lot was happening i lost my car you
know i was just barely surviving i
continued to work and everything but
i had some issues and when i did that
and
the detox is in walking distance from my
house
and so after i got out of the detox and
walked home it was the first time i ever
saw my house
my street first time you ever saw it
meaning you first time you saw it
and it was like terms where i could
really see it and not seen it through a
face
or through through a haze or you know
because i i lived in fantasy or i was
you know hiding out in plain sight so i
didn't know that until i
noticed that oh i'm really seeing you
know i really see things
but it was more about me really seeing
life and seeing myself
for the first time without having the
influence of
substances or hiding out in my own
little inner fantasy world
how did mindfulness
in any capacity enter your life
what happened was just to give you a
little insight my spiritual experience
of my first mindfulness or
meditative experience that i can think
of that that was powerful
was that day i got out of the detox and
maybe it was the next day
i went to work when i went to work i i
had like it was three weeks
out of work i had all this money waiting
for me and the obsession the loot
the use the compulsion obsession to use
came upon me this is the thing i got
triggered
and i knew that if i were to go into the
restroom in the men's room and just
recite the serenity prayer
god grant me the serenity to accept the
things i cannot change
the courage to change the things i can
and the wisdom to know the difference i
did that like a mantra
just repeating it silently over and over
and the obsession was removed
and i had some stabilization so that was
my first experience
but what also happened when i got clean
i had chronic pain
my migraine headaches which if anybody
ever had a migraine headache you know
when it gets to a point
doesn't matter what they give you it's
just not enough
and i had chronic back pains which i had
since college
i used to sleep on a bed board and i've
been going to a chiropractor since 1975
so what's that 46 years
yeah so i was going to chiropractic
before you know when it was still
wasn't viewed like it is today so i had
a lot of pain
i was dealing with my pain administering
pain medicine
not just physical but emotional and
probably spiritual pain
see you use the serenity prayer as this
sort of grounding mantra that helps you
to stabilize
and then from where does the
mindfulness or meditation come so i had
the chronic
pain and so at the same time i was in a
hmo
back in those days and and they had this
experimental program so i was
and i had a therapist i was working with
to help me you know sort out stuff so i
can go into the detox and
i was working with him and when i got
out we were talking about strategies
and they had this experimental program
run out of beth
israel run by dr joe borisenko who at
the time was one of the three
psychoneuro psychoneuroimmunologists in
the world it just means mind-body
medicine and the endocrine system and
that sort of thing
so they had the stress management
program so i signed up and i had a
pee and spit and they'd take pre and
post testing
and what they did was they introduced us
to this idea
of taking responsibility for ourselves
learning about the mind-body process
but being an active participant with the
healthcare that we were getting whether
it's the doctor or whatever
and that's where i learned about
meditation and
mindfulness and yoga and and some of the
mind-body practices like tai chi and
yoga
obviously and they gave us a syllabus
a bunch of books to read i don't know if
they had 20 25 books on that list i read
every one of those books and then i read
books that they recommended so
i'm 36 years and
six months clean and sober and i have
averaged over a book a week
during that time so i just really got
into understanding
i wanted to understand how did i get
clean and others don't what was the
motivation how do i
enhance my ability to grow and develop
and so i got really
stimulated intellectually stimulated
around that and that's how i got into
this whole thing of mindfulness and then
i was doing that and that helped with my
recovery i was already in 12 steps my
recovery was
pretty good because i was connected to
the spirit or i had my concept of god
which worked for me and
allowed me to understand that there is a
power grid in myself
and that all i had to do is basically
there's a plug in the wall all i had to
do was plug into the power source and
and i would be able to do things and
then as a natural outgrowth of
that she suggested that i go to do a
retreat at this place in very mass
called insight meditation society
and so i did a weekend retreat there and
then i
was introduced to the cambridge insight
meditation center which is in this
in cambridge right in the city and you
could go there and do day longs and
stuff like that so that's how i got into
it and then
while i was doing that my teacher there
larry rosenberg
was good friend with john kapitzen after
three four years of recovery i connected
with john and then
i did the mindfulness-based stress
reduction and then i ended up working
in the um center for mindfulness so at
that time it was called
stress reduction relaxation program i
ended up working there for five years
i had a prison project and then we
developed an inner city
project but i lived at the meditation
center in cambridge for six years
while i was working in two years where i
wasn't working where i was just
meditating and reading and studying and
teaching going out from the center would
get these requests from
different outlets it could be a youth
center it could be
a business like att or 9x at the time
and i would go out and i would teach
mindfulness i would teach meditation a
harvard business school
so i was doing my training to become a
teacher at the same time i was
continuing to grow and evolve and then
when i worked at the center for
mindfulness it was
part of my job is to teach
mindfulness-based stress reduction but
really it was more about teaching them
the same process i had it's the inner
game and how to
take control of your life in the sense
of being responsible
and understanding how the mind and body
work and how we
can relate to our experience in a way
that leads to more peace ease freedom
compassion that's one hell of a
u-turn and self-transformation and i'm
also still thinking about
the stacks of books that would represent
the number of books you've read
over that period of time that you
mentioned were there any
books in the beginning that really
ignited you or any books that you
remember
really grabbing your attention because
you you
really applied yourself in a very
wholehearted way
and i'm wondering what some of the
catalysts might have been were any books
particularly impactful or conversations
wonder was on a new york best seller
list for like 10 years
the road less traveled by um scott peck
but also zen mine began his mind he was
a lot of books pain is motivator
love is letting go of fear and there
were a lot of different
books but the bible was always in there
it's interesting i was doing like
a presentation at lululemon for about a
thousand people a couple years ago
and they asked me well what book would i
recommend and i was thinking about
because there's tons of books
depends on where you are what books work
for you and i said
uh the bible and i don't know where that
came from it just came out of my
deep sense and i said well that makes
sense because
there's one in every hotel room and
there's a lot of stuff in there
and i said the acronym that i remember
is ask
a-s-k and that is asking it shall be
given to you
seeking ye shall find knock and it
should be open to you it's amazing i
went to some
sunday school until i was 13 then i
stopped going to church
and yet as i get older all of those
sayings like
there's even mindfulness in the bible a
double-minded man is unstable in all his
ways
and i started realizing that spiritual
truth is spiritual truth whether it
comes out of the bible or the koran
or the kabbalah it doesn't matter or
from the buddhist teachings
it's all that wisdom literature and
philosophy i've
read a lot of movers stuff
i endow the way of man i got really
drawn to existentialism
when i went back to graduate school and
i studied victor franco and
man's search for meaning and what i call
the religious existentialists like
victor franco
and martin buber and then there's camus
satra
kierkegaard if we look at the entire
spectrum of books you've read
i'll try to help narrow them down and
then we'll we'll move into some
different lines of questioning but
what books would you say aside from your
own that you have
gifted to other people or recommended
the most to other people
those people could be high-level
athletes i'm just wondering if there are
a handful of books that you tend to
gift the most or recommend the most to
other people
as in my beginner's mind used to be one
that i would recommend
years ago so it depends on on the time
and who the person is
but i think more recently when talking
about performance when i'm working with
clients it's
there's a book called the three laws of
performance this is what that looks like
this is a really good one
steve saffron and dave lewis yeah yeah
and then on becoming a leader
these are the books that i've been
reading recently by
warren bennis
the thing i like about it he says to
become a leader you have to become
yourself
so i've been focusing on leadership a
little bit more
recently but any of the books that you
know some of the books about the
teachings of the buddha or
psychology books i read a lot of rallo
may
the meaning of anxiety eric fromm
it's a bunch of guys obviously victor
franco's book man search for meaning
be a good one it's really challenging
for me to answer that question because
it's fluid yeah totally depends on the
person as well
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs small business owners have
always shown an incredible ability to
adapt
and innovate this past year has
certainly highlighted many
examples now another way you can adapt
and innovate in 2021 is by finding the
right people
to help you grow your business linkedin
jobs makes it possible for you to do
exactly that
get started by posting your job for free
to reach linkedin's network of more than
740
million professionals fill out targeted
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified candidates
with the experience skills and
motivation you're looking for
then with simple filtering and
management tools you can easily review
rate and home in on your top candidates
linkedin jobs
can help you find the right person to
help you grow your business and your
first job post
is free so just visit linkedin.com
tim to learn more again that's
linkedin.com
tim to post your first job for free
terms and conditions do
apply
well it seems like you're traveling this
path you've gone from
competitive athlete then to
working and using simultaneously you
become sober
you're still working but then the nature
of your self-work certainly changes
and you're developing this ability
cultivating this greater awareness this
ability to
observe your own thinking how did elite
sports
enter the picture how did you end up
becoming connected
to that world when i was working at the
medical center
and at that time we had the prison
project we were in about five
department of corrections massachusetts
department of corrections
prisons but i also taught at their
training facility i used to work with
staff
do two cycles a year teaching the staff
of mindfulness-based stress reduction
at that time john used to go to this
place called omega institute
john robinson john kaepernick and uh he
was out there
him and his partner saki santorelli and
then they met
and phil used to do a program called
beyond basketball
there so they were there on campus at
the same time and they were talking and
this is phil jackson joe jackson phil
jackson
that's okay which a lot of people would
have seen from the last dance
yes so at that summer interaction
phil was and his wife at the time in
june
they were interested in having somebody
come in and work with the bulls out
because they had just won
three nba championships in a row and so
they were given a presentation and then
they saw me and they said well who's
this guy and
she worked with he said yeah this is
george mumford he went with dr j
and you know he does this and they said
he would be perfect
for our team and so phil and i talked
and he invited me to training camp in
1993
and in the interim we talked in july in
the interim michael jordan's father got
murdered and michael
retired when i showed up in chicago in
october in 1993 they were full-blown
crisis and then i went in and i had to
pretty much doing the intervention with
the team and then talking to them about
this process of i talked about being a
spiritual warrior
just like martial art you have to train
a certain way and so i talked about
martial arts i studied tai chi for a lot
of years
i brought zen and martial arts that's
what i
i presented to them and then being in
the zone being in flow
that's how it all started and then it
just took off from there
let's approach this from a bunch of
different angles the first angle
i'd love to cover is
what phil believed the team needed
or why he felt
it would be well served by having your
skill set or you there
what what was it that he hoped to
accomplish phil
we have a similar philosophy you may
recall
when lebron james entered into the
political sphere
they told him to just dribble and shut
up phil looks at the whole person as a
basketball player with a body mind heart
and soul
and so to him his job is to care for
them
from beyond basketball and they had just
won three nba championships
they were dealing with the stress of
success what happens when you become
successful everybody comes at you they
want something
he wanted them to be prepared and wanted
to support them
in their ability to sustain that success
and to continue to grow
and evolve as people not just basketball
players and so
bringing me in to help them deal with
the stress of success because i was
working in a stress reduction clinic it
made a lot of sense
and i i had similar backgrounds and i i
played basketball i was an
athlete and i was around celebrity dr j
was michael jordan before
michael jordan so even when i was in
college
being his roommate everywhere he went it
was like not quite like the beatles but
everybody would come in
and he just couldn't go many places
because he would draw a crowd he had a
certain level of charisma and stuff so i
had my experience
i had the experience of and i used to go
visit him when he played in the aba
so i've been around the nba and that
sort of thing so it made
perfect sense for me to go in and to
teach them how to deal with
the stress of success that was the
initial thing but of course when i
had gone down there they were had an
identity crisis as well as
an opportunity to grow and that's what i
proposed
to the team is a crisis has two meanings
one meaning is danger which we get but
the other
meaning is opportunity this is an
opportunity to look just like me it's an
opportunity
my substance abuse wasn't a curse it was
a blessing
wouldn't be who i was if i didn't
experience that
how do we relate to life in a way where
it empowers and inspires us
that's why when i was down here that's
why
i work so well with phil because if he
didn't have my philosophy
if he had the philosophy just shut up
and dribble i i wouldn't be able to work
with him
had phil tried other approaches
to impart even if this word is
appropriate as the objective
mindfulness had he tried other things
before or was
were you just the perfect vehicle in his
mind for
introducing the players to some of these
skills to answer your question yes
that's what happened
i came in and he realized that it could
work and especially
it's nothing like baptism you know
baptism right yes that's what it was
okay oh it's okay when everything's nice
but what's gonna happen when
when everybody's blessed on fire how's
he gonna is he gonna be able to meet the
challenge
i think that phil used to do sessions
with the guys but it was obvious and he
says it in his books
that it made sense for somebody from the
outside to come in
and because i could do it in a way where
they could listen to me and i had a
user-friendly language you know i could
teach in any domain that was all those
years going
and making house calls if you will not
working in the main
centers or the traditional places but
going where people lived and being able
to talk to them in a language they could
understand
but yet give them the essence of the
teachings
but he has it from time to time he's he
brought in yoga teachers he brought in
somebody to teach them tai chi but the
thing was i think a lot of people
can have the training in these
disciplines
but you have to meet people where they
are and so they would come in and i
remember having conversations with this
one particular person
and i told her i said they just had two
and a half hour practice you can't take
them through two hours of yoga
you can't do it or you have to make it
real for them
and you have to understand that less is
more
might be better for you to teach them
how to stretch and relax a little bit
and then
depending on their situation and you can
teach them some people
maybe need more standing yoga poses
whatever so my whole idea was you got to
start with
the understanding of what you can do to
help
the situation and you got to meet people
where they were so a lot of people i
think
at least in some cases they come in not
understanding
that the context is more important than
the content
that's a really that's a really really
important
concept in line to underscore right the
context is more important than the
content and this
in so much as what that brings to mind
for me is that
the tendency the very understandable
impulse that a lot of people have to
copy and paste whatever
is working in one place to another place
but right
that just doesn't necessarily work like
you said if someone's just come out of a
two and a half hour
practice and they're going a hundred
percent
they don't have the slack in the system
to do
two hours of yoga and i read that
as you noted one of the things you
observed when you first started working
with chicago bulls was that they're
dealing with
all types of distractions that you don't
necessarily get exposed to
until you're at a higher level and that
the more successful a person
or team becomes the more distractions
there are so it actually gets in some
respects
very difficult to continue doing the
things that got you to where you are
in the first place so they're getting
requests for tickets from friends
and other hangers on right before some
of the most important games
all manners of shiny objects
and obstacles and distractions what were
some of the
recommendations you made or tools you
suggested
anything to these players so they could
turn down the volume on some of these
distractions yes
the thing is understanding that
whatever you're doing you're going to be
fully present to it and understand what
are you doing and what are the
consequences
what's it costing you how much energy
can you
allow for this activity versus the next
activity
i would say a lot of things and one
thing i would say to them is don't
believe the hype
so what does that mean that means that
when you go get interviewed
they tell you you're the greatest thing
since sliced bread you say thank you and
you just smile and if they tell you
you're the biggest choke artist of all
time you just thank them
and smile so it's more about how they
relate to people
and just not give energy to that it's
just really understanding that what's
really important you have to understand
that even though you have your family
with you even though there's certain
things that are going on
you have to create a kind of a cocoon
for yourself to be ready to play
and so your rituals your rituals the day
of the game and
so i would talk to them about rituals
but it was really more about
there's no such thing as multitasking
that you just do one thing at a time so
if you have a process where
you're going to write tickets for a
certain amount of time at certain time
during
the pregame thing then you do that then
you set that aside then
you have to have your space and time for
your
readiness for you to get ready to play
but i didn't really get into that they'd
have to ask me about it back in those
days it was really different
it was like they had a volunteer whereas
now
the analogy i would use is before it was
like
lazy fair the ones who wanted to do it
fine once it didn't
that's fine but i have the analogy of if
you have somebody out in the rain
can at least go out there with an
umbrella and ask them if they want to
come in
you know so you just meet them where
they are and then if you can kind of
bring them in
but some people they thrive i mean
everybody's different some people like
quiet some people want
you know rousing music it's different
like dennis rodman
in the lab but it's really more about
them
it was really more about teaching them
from moment to moment
how they're relating to their experience
and understanding the quality of mind
that they have the mind state that they
have and how to just be
in the moment and to be clear about what
you're doing and what you're getting
and the willingness to adjust and adapt
like you said what gets you here
is just what that is it got you here but
to go beyond that you have to let go to
grow
and you have to be willing to develop
other habit patterns other ways of being
to go to continue to evolve and to grow
so it's really more about
the inner game and them getting clarity
about
what they want and who they're being and
how to
develop the me but the wii has to be the
context in which the me is operating so
let's talk about meeting people where
they are
because that person in the rain you
might have
not to stretch the metaphor too far but
you might have one person who's doing
jumping jacks and smiling one person
who's huddling in a corner
another person who's who knows drinking
out of a puddle
there are so many different
personalities right
and i was reading a piece in the boston
globe
and man i mean you the the types of
testimonials that you have the belief
that other people
ascribe to you is just incredible i
and i'll just read a little piece here
as from the boston globe
a piece in 2015. this is kobe bryant
he's basically
saying i'm going to paraphrase here so
he's saying that
many people tried to get him to meditate
kobe bryant once told an interviewer
quote but i couldn't sit still for 20
minutes
under the tutelage of phil jackson
mumford however meditation became a key
to game preparation for bryant and for
his teammate and feud counterpart
shaquille o'neal there weren't a lot of
things that shaq and kobe agreed on says
lazenby another person in this piece
but they both agreed on the
effectiveness of george mumford okay
could you speak to the differences
or similarities in teaching
say michael jordan versus kobe versus
shaquille o'neal
some of the tools in your toolkit like
how did you approach those
seemingly very different personalities
when i say talk about meeting people
where they are i let the wisdom and the
mindfulness dictate what i do i have to
get
insight i have to get a clarity of okay
what's the context
how do i deal with this person one size
does not fit all
it has to be a specificity of really
getting clear but also getting clear in
my mind what's my intention
but at the same time it's just going in
and just figuring out
how to relate to them in a way that
makes sense if you think about
about the great spiritual teachers like
jesus of buddha
they talk in parables or if they're
going to talk to carpenters they're
going to use carpentry
examples if you're going to talk to
people
who are bricklayers or stone masons
you're going to use that language
to express the essence of what you're
talking about so when you talk to people
about
if you create a vision of possibility
where you say hey
you're challenged with this or you want
to achieve this you might consider
doing this because this can enhance you
and by the way you know i did this with
this person or you know i know the
elites they do that
yeah i went with jay jay dr j i'm
talking about and he
you know i know for a fact there's
certain practices people have there's
certain ways of being
that you can have so some people are
auditory
some people are visual some people are
kinesthetic so i have to meet them
in that modality where they can take in
information so a lot of it is connecting
with them i don't know how to say it
and then and then feeling your way
through just being
present with it and relating to them as
each individual
and understanding how what will work for
them when i first started doing this
i didn't like standing still i used to
do more walking meditation than sitting
or do more tai chi or more yoga but
i talk about sometimes you got to move
your way into stillness
i like that that's great and then
sometimes and you have stillness and
movement
it's my teacher my seafood used to talk
about this movement and stillness and
stillness and movement
so you have to understand my modality is
more like physical
so how do i move myself in this
stillness
can you give any examples any specific
examples
or stories related to working with say
kobe or shaq i'm curious to know what
this looks like
in practice if any moments or stories or
examples come to mind
it's interesting because i spent a lot
of my time just just sitting there
observing
most of it is observing and getting a
sense for where people are and then
finding the moments
when i can go in and give them a
teaching or talk to them about something
they're dealing with
i had a conversation with kobe early on
and
my first year i worked with them when i
said to kobe the best way to score is
not to
try to score because i saw that he was
trying really hard and several years ago
when he invited me to go down to newport
beach and hang out with him i asked him
about that
and he said that he remembered
everything i told him he has like a
photographic
memory but it's picking the time to
really ask them how they're seeing
things or talk to them about okay i know
you want to achieve this
think about this a lot of people think
that the practice
of mindfulness the practice of insight
meditation is just sitting and being
still
is a big part of it is is cultivating
wisdom
and talking about integrity talking
about
walking your talk but also understanding
how to cultivate
a sense of compassion for yourself and
others and how to
i guess love is the way i would talk
about it you when you love something you
label for it
you make it grow and so talking about
this heart to heart just talking about
well if this is what you're interested
in here's an application
there's a way of thinking or looking at
it and you might consider these things
could you explain what the dizziness of
freedom is i've heard you use this
phrase before
yes and it really stuck with me
could you please explain what this is
and how you see it
freedom is not free if you will
so the dizziness of freedom it's because
you're on you're in the road less
traveled or you're on shaky ground the
ground you're on is moving
to the degree that and i'm going back to
1846
sword and kirkuk god and he said
that one side of the coin is freedom or
potential the heads the other side
is anxiety or uncertainty he called it
the alarming possibility of being able
[Laughter]
when you change a behavior or a habit
you have to experience anxiety you have
to experience
uncertainty you have to experience
discomfort
because we're comfortable with where we
are and so when we grow
the only way that happens is you got to
be able to be a little bit uncomfortable
you got to be beyond
your comfort zone you got to have a
discomfort zone where you go into
and then because we adapted things then
you will adapt so it's possible
you get comfortable with being
uncomfortable so the dizziness of
freedom is
like okay before when you didn't have
freedom you did the same thing
you don't have to think you don't have
to reflect you don't have to take a risk
you don't have to be vulnerable
but now you're being freedom and you're
going to a different door you're trying
something else
then the dizziness of it is you do this
thing but you can do that thing
how do you make a choice out of all of
these options
and you want to have more options
because if you only have two options on
some level
it's restricting but on another level is
yes either or
so when you start understanding that
this is there's
no meaning in the universe other than
what you give it
or even though you could do this then
you can also do that
thing and when you do this thing you no
longer have those things so if i have
five choices
and i make one i lose four so now i'm in
here and now i'm worried about did i
make the right choice
so the uncertainty a military term they
use vuca
vuca for moment the moment things are
volatile
uncertain complex and ambiguous so you
have to embrace
uncertainty ambiguity that's part of the
life this is what life is about it's
about saying yes and
yes it's frustrating it's unpleasant and
it's okay this is it when i grow this is
what comes with it
if i achieve my goals you look at the
positive but there's a negative
the other side is you're in a rowboat
with people you change they got to
change they got to move they don't want
to move
[Laughter]
well they got you in the box and now
you're out of the box so now they got to
refigure who you are
they're going to keep you in the box and
get mad at you so for whatever reason
but it always comes down to discomfort
being uncomfortable the nervous system
is wired this way if it's pleasant we
move
approach it's unpleasant we avoid and if
it's neither with indifference we space
out
it's what the nervous system does so
when you impute
meaning onto something and say it's
going to be great
even though it's uncomfortable i know on
the other side this is the only way out
it's true then once i commit to that and
i have the experience of going through
it and then coming to another level of
grace
of ease of peace then
i continue to do that that's what i talk
about the superpower of trust
you need trust but when you can verify
it through insight
through information through experience
now and it goes from
confidence to conviction and then now
you you get on a beneficial
cycle where things keep getting the
grits get richer
because you know that if you learn and
you achieve
it's going to generate enthusiasm and
you're going to want to learn more
you're going to want to commit to it
because you know that and this is what
the elites do
they see those things as challenges oh
this is great this is an opportunity for
me to express myself
that mindset is the growth mindset but
it's also
pursuing excellence let's talk about
growth and excellence
and i'd love to frame it through a
contrast that i've read you make and
you've written about this and there
there are examples of this on
georgemomford.com
the or a barrier breakthrough versus the
improvement trap
could you explain for people what these
two things are
incremental improvements means you're
just improving
but when you have a paradigm shift then
it's totally different because when
you're improving something okay i'm
going to improve this show i'm going to
do it so that can be a trap it can be
helpful
but it can be a trap because you're just
looking to improve instead of
looking to break out as
stephen covey says every breakthrough is
a break with
so you you have to change the paradigm
so you have to change how you see
yourself
so if you keep so michael jordan's what
did he say when he hit the
winning shot against georgetown in the
ncaa
he said i went for mike jordan to
michael jordan
see what i'm saying so he had a paradigm
shift and realized okay i'm great not
i'm going to be great or i can be great
i'm a great player i see myself as
michael jordan
capable of doing everything when you
have a breakthrough that means
you're changing how you see things and
when you change how you see things
then things change so when you change
how you see things
the things you look at change the
constant improvement is great to have
improvement
but a breakout has to do with you could
be improving and being a little pawn
and it's good for the little pawn but to
really break out to really
go beyond that is you have to just have
crazy initiative it's nice i can hit
singles all day i'm playing baseball
just get a single but
you want to be able to not only hit a
single but hit hit whatever the heck you
want hit home runs hit
hit whatever so i would say the vision
of possibility is bigger than one
versus the other where it's keeping you
playing small and it's comfortable
versus being big and having a breakout
right having that complete kind of shift
of
perspective in it sounds like
particularly as
as you mentioned in the mike jordan to
michael jordan
it's a shift in how juan views
themselves are there any other
examples that you can think of things
you've seen
in athletes or others that have
really stuck in your mind that stand out
in your memory other
breakthroughs or breakouts like this
where
not over a long period of time but in an
instant or in a single game in a single
practice maybe
over a a week or a month you see a real
quantum leap
in someone you've worked with one of the
athletes i work with at boston college
name is troy bell he's a point guard
i think he owes a record in bc for the
most points scored
troy as a sophomore
we were playing in the biggest he he got
biggest player of the year
he was co-player of the year with murphy
from
notre dame his junior year
it was kind of okie doke then he came
back and he seen it again he won
player of the year outright and as a
matter of fact you saw where his game
was
going he was increasing and then it just
took off
in january in the senior year he just
went to a whole other level
with his play so much so that sports
illustrator came and interviewed him
when they told him he says well you know
work with george and you know just a
mental game is all that stuff
that we were working on all of a sudden
it just took off in a linear perspective
you say one plus one equals two
but in a non-linear or right brain if
you're left right handed
one plus one equals six you get a jump
so that happened with
troy the team he was playing on boston
college
eagles al skinner's team was my roommate
from college
one year he was six and 21 six wins 21
losses
the next year the team was 11 and 19
and out of those 19 losses 12
losses came in a row when they lost in
the last possession of the game
the next year a same team which you
played 16 games in league so
big east you played 16 games that first
year where they were 11 and 19
they won three games and last 13. the
next year
they won 13 games the last three so they
were 27 and five
it kept going and then it just took off
i could say the same thing
the same thing about the the bulls you
know when they won 72 games
you know they struggle they go through
it then you take off
you chip away at it but because slow
motion gets you there quicker
it's like the tortoise in the hair you
just keep doing what's in front of you
you
you staying locked in you stay in
enthusiastic you do what you have to do
then something happens it happens a lot
of the time you just
break out you have a breakout because
you're not just improving you're looking
and these guys had
a vision so that team that was 27 and 5
that year we had what they call a
european trip
so we're in the gym in august before
they go and
i'm hanging around i'm listening and the
guys are saying you know we've been
getting beat by 40
by all these teams any team that comes
in here this year we're going to beat
them by 20.
that's self-image that's a shift in
consciousness
right and it's very concrete too very
specific
yeah and you know what their record was
that year 17-0
and they won by 22 and a half points i'd
be curious to know
since you've sort of tracked yourself
and
your sort of development over a long
period of time
if you look back at the younger george
say
in the first year of working with
high-level athletes
is there any advice that you would give
him now
just with the benefit of hindsight i
would tell him to focus on
self-observation teaching them how to
observe their experience
in a uncritical way where they can start
to see okay
if i'm shooting free throws let's just
talk about shooting free throws
when i go up and i shoot a free throw i
want to be able to deserve
what happened you know i miss the free
throw a lot of times people say shoot i
miss the free throw
i want them to be able to say okay so
i'm observing it
so when i shot the free throw what did i
notice that was off that i use my feet
did i keep my
elbow in did i stick it and it's just a
matter of like okay so what do i need to
change
okay i need to stick it next time if you
go back to
michael jordan playing in 1998
against the utah jazz in the fourth
quarter he was shooting shots and they
were short
yeah so what adjustment did he make
so when he shot the shot he stuck it can
you explain sticking it to people
visually right yes that's more extension
through the wrist yeah
but it's really more like sticking that
like this like like follow through
follow through right what he did was he
made the adjustment
my shot is short so to get it up i have
to
get it up and stick it so you see in
real time
he'll make an adjustment but how does
that work so i talk about the four a's
so the four a's have to do with
awareness
the kind of awareness that you could
just notice
you know this uncritical it's
mindfulness you just notice like never
mind you you're aware of
what happened okay i'm shooting my jump
shot and it's flat
then the acceptance of it that's the hot
challenging part
because sometimes you say oh man you
know i just rushed it or whatever you're
not taking responsibility for it and
saying yeah i don't like it
it sucks it feels bad but once i embrace
it and say this is what happened
this is notion true shall make you free
you know that it was short and then
what's the compassion in action
compassionate action is what okay what
do i need to do to fix it
i need to stick it that's all i need to
do is just follow through
then the assessment afterwards is so
there's awareness
acceptance which is the big challenging
thing action
compassionate action and assessment what
worked what didn't work
and then then go back to it so if you're
practicing meditation you're sitting and
you notice
that you're sitting but your mind keeps
thinking about
let's do what happens a lot of people
i'm listening to a song on the radio
like
they say stop me up by mick jagger or
whatever
and you heard on the radio and you're in
your meditation and they start me up
and it keeps going and the more you try
to avoid it it keeps staying there
then you go through the sitting and you
say well the whole time i was struggling
with this damn song i couldn't get rid
of it
the awareness is this song or this it
could be a thought pattern or whatever
it could be something we're worried
about like somebody's sick and worried
about how the operation went or
something like that
so the instructions are when you get
distracted just go back to your breath
or be with the body but you spend all
the time doing that but it's a struggle
and it's hard to do it the awareness of
that then the acceptance is yeah i
couldn't do it
but then the compassionate action is
okay so george what do you do
here's what i teach so if this becomes
so much
of a distraction instead of fighting it
just turn your attention towards it and
that becomes the object
what is this and so by not resisting it
by
looking at then you know so what is it
what does it feel like you know
this song you know what does it feel
like in my body what is it
why is it this song is staying there
maybe there's something about stop me up
or jimmy henry who knows
you know or you know the power of love
well it could be whatever it is
but then we look at it but we just
notice that it's just thinking
and we just instead of resisting it we
turn attention to it
and we open it up okay what is this and
you just let it be there the acceptance
and then by doing that you notice that
you'll come down
and then because all you're doing is
taking this instead of being
attached to this object you just take
whatever comes up
okay this is here let's just go with
that notice the song
you just focus on that and you will
still get concentrated because you focus
on one thing
so that's where you know the awareness
the acceptance but if i'm going through
this every day for five days in a row
if it's not that it's something else and
i'm struggling i just can't stay on the
object
what i'm gonna do is say i can't do this
this is not for me i'm not able to do it
instead of saying no it's just
noticing what's happening you're
distracted and it's instead of fighting
it
just let it become your object of
awareness this is part of the process
and then when you do that then you're
going to get to this place of calm
then you can let go and then you can
just come back to wherever you are but
you have to be aware of it you have to
accept it yeah it's happening
i suck as a meditator that's all
judgment it's awareness without
being critical or without judgment and
then
or passionate action is just notice okay
let's see what the mind takes is maybe
the mind is telling us something and you
focus on that
then you come back and then you notice
that there's more ease
and so then your assessment of it is
what worked what didn't work what did
you change
so now you have that ability so it could
be a sound
it could be aching your body
now you have the same thing so you're
aware of your breathing but
there's this twisting burning and
maybe it's anxiety and you have this
tightness in your chest and you're like
this
so instead of avoiding that you open to
it you focus on that say what is this
and can i open and can i just breathe
and just let it be there what's the
sensation okay
it's tightness but then at some point
it's going to change it's going to
dissipate
because i'm not fighting it then i can
move on so that's what i mean by the
four
a's yeah i like it i like the forays and
the
you know the examples that you gave of
turning
let's just say what people might
consider a problem into the object
makes me think of this it's basically a
fortune cookie
that i was given at one point to carry
my wallet
or that i ended up carrying my wallet
and it said
that which hinders your task is your
task and
i think it's it's a very helpful
framework this four
is especially for beginning meditators
because it's so
easy without that type of perspective
to become very frustrated and to beat
yourself up
it's a very valuable very valuable
approach so thank you for that
yeah so can i give you an example a
story that illustrates this
so i was working in this prison norfolk
county house of correction actually the
little tidbit is there that's what
malcolm x did his time in that prison i
actually saw his jacket
you know his package right so i used to
work in there
and so i go in there to teach this
meditation class
or this meditation yoga class but the
meditation class
and i have all these copious notes this
is when i was really
and i was going to give them a sermon or
a lecture or
diamond talk whatever you want to call
it it's going to be awesome i got all
these notes in there
and everything so and this also goes
into what bruce lee talks about be like
water
i go in there and then when i get into
class i realize that out of
32 students 28 of them are spanish
speaking only
[Laughter]
so so the awareness the acceptance
okay what's the compassion in action
okay i got an interpreter i got to make
this [ __ ] real simple
i gotta just just give them the basic
things
breathe in breathe out whatever you know
it's something about
being in the present and what that looks
like and that's when
all the notes went out the window yeah
and i just had to just be like well just
okay what is
what is here how can i work with it just
to
i won't say surrender i say embrace it
and then generate the hope
what can i do how can i still i have to
keep it simple but i can just show up
and do things
and so that applies and then we can fast
forward to
you like stories i'll give you another
story well once again how did that talk
turn out how did it turn out it turned
out great yeah because they got
something and i got something
and i realized that what it told me was
especially working in prison you have no
idea what the hell is going to happen
and then then the alarm goes off and
everybody gets locked out
right right so how did it go it went
great because
i gave them what they could hear i met
them where they were
but the main thing was i wasn't rigid i
wasn't attached to my
wanting to force something on them i'd
say okay they're not gonna be able to
hear this so what can i do how can i be
of service
and so i just went right into it but i
laughed because i said all that
preparation and it just kind of goes and
so that's the same thing so whatever
happens
can we say yes to it can we embrace it
and then
generate the hope or say okay what can
we do what's the next plate
this is an opportunity for us to figure
out what we need to do and maybe if we
don't know
well just start with just sitting and
just being present
with what's going on i had a friend of
mine his name is bo lozov
he passed away but he he was doing a
thing in prison
and he decided to bring the men and the
women together and when he did that it
was
other chaos and he was there and you
know what he did
he sat down and meditated right in the
middle of them and they all got quiet
he had no idea what the hell they do so
he said i was just going to sit and
think about
you know see what happened and they all
looked at him and said well how could he
do that
if you think about your experience or
even the listeners if you think about a
time when you were able to just say okay
this is what it is what can i do how can
i relate to it that's what it is so
awareness
acceptance once you accept it then you
can do something about it
so you're not in deny or you're not
blaming somebody you're saying okay
this is what it is how can i do about it
so those four a's can apply
anytime anywhere that's a great story
what are you most excited about these
days personally
personally i'm excited about the fact
that that i get to
do what i was put here to do and be a
service
and just show up i'm in this journey of
discovery where i have no idea what's
going to happen with covid and
and all the other things my job is like
i said to show up
and to be myself which in my case is
i want to be loving i want to be
compassionate but i want to be helpful
to show up be myself and have fun it's
like okay so
i had to be like why so whatever is
coming can i embrace it
and create a container to hold it and at
the same time generate
okay how can i relate to this in a way
that inspires motivates moves
is helpful yeah it is there's certainly
a world of uncertainty right now it's
a ripe opportunity for practicing a lot
of what you discuss
and it's really highlighted how much is
outside of our control
yes but at the same time han cellier got
the the scientists that came up with the
stress of life and the stress reaction
and
all of that is his belief and it's also
my belief that when the crisis or when
there's
a challenge that's when our latent
abilities express themselves
it's like seeing everything so we know
this that how you can predict how
somebody
doesn't a job three things what they
call
positive genius or optimism and hope
second thing is social support
and the third thing is seeing a crisis
as a challenge
and so when we can do that now we
generate we stimulate
these latent abilities oh this is great
this is an opportunity
to show up and to really be helpful
so that's what i'm excited about is it
really doesn't matter what happens on
somewhere
what matters is can i create space
between stimulus and response
and in that space can i be loving can i
be compassionate can i be
wise i make wise choices and can i live
according to what my core values are
love compassion connection that sort of
thing and that no matter what happens
i need to train myself so i can keep
showing up but the good news is
because i share i give away what i have
i get more of it
and if i want to learn something i teach
it
george i want to commend you for the
work you do in the world
and also the fact that you
share what you've learned in your story
and the tools not just
with the celebrities that are known
worldwide
but that you've also dedicated a
substantial
part of your life to at-risk populations
people who are looking for new ways to
change
new chapters and transitions into a
better way of being and i just think
that's really a manifestation
of love in you
and it's beautiful to witness that and
to know that there are people like you
offering that so i just want to thank
you thank you and these people like you
that they give me a
opportunity to share my experience
strength and hope and it's also
wonderful because i know the impact
you've been having
on folks and continue to have so i want
to say ditto
to you but i i'm i'm just happy man i'm
just happy that that i can
just be here and have this wonderful
conversation about how do we live in a
solution
not in a problem and how do we access
the fact that we are already
perfect whole and complete in terms of
being a masterpiece or divine spark
we just don't know it or we don't show
it i think that
is that is an excellent
piece to anchor on as we as we come to a
close george is there anything else that
you would like to say
any question you'd like to post to the
audience or request you'd like to make
of people listening before we wrap up
yes my wish for everyone is for everyone
to really understand they have a
masterpiece and how to
know ourselves so we can be ourselves so
we can express ourselves so we can share
ourselves
so the sharing is really important and
just understanding that we have a
masterpiece and
i have my book i have my online course i
have my youtube channel
and you have all sorts of resources
my hope is that we all understand
that we have to take personal
responsibility as an inner game
and if we don't like what we are
experiencing we can change it
but we have to be willing and also
not letting blame or denial prevent us
from taking responsibility and being
able to
to share the focus on the solution so if
we're going to criticize somebody it's
one thing to say
i don't like this it's another thing to
say it and then give them my option
it's helpful very different worlds
of difference and that goes for
criticizing other people or
criticizing yourself it applies in so
many ways
george people can find you at
georgemomford.com
certainly on instagram we'll link to all
these things in the show notes as well
at george.mom for twitter gt
mumford and they can find the mindful
athlete course
certainly on your website your book is
the mindful athlete subtitle
secrets to pure performance
and to everyone listening we'll link to
everything that we've discussed
including the youtube channel and so on
in the show notes at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast as per always
and george thank you so much for taking
the time
thank you appreciate you and to
everybody listening
until next time thank you for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
that's 4hourworkweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
tonal that's t-o-n-a-l tonal is the
world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer that's the tagline
from their website folks
so it gives you the one sentence summary
by eliminating traditional metal weights
total can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen
tv it mounts right on your wall with no
floor space required
i've had one for a few months now after
a number of close friends
recommended tonal to me and it allows me
to do things that i would normally need
a huge
gym for like cable chop and lift or
rotational exercises and it allows me to
do other things
that are nearly impossible otherwise
like eccentric loading which i'll talk
about again later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights
and ai learning together with the best
experts in resistance training so you
can get stronger
faster one of my friends who used to be
a competitive skier
very high level competitive skier has
doubled his strength in many exercises
over a period of months
so what are these adaptive digital
weights tonal's patented
digital weight system makes thousands of
calculations a second to deliver you a
smooth weightlifting experience using
your advanced electronic motor
technology
and a lot of the buttons are built right
into the handles themselves
into the grips so you don't need to move
around and
it is extremely easy to use tonal lets
you adjust the weight in one pound
increments and you can do it on the fly
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down
with just the touch of a button tonal
also has built-in dynamic weight modes
like chains eccentric and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains and bands
the eccentrics which i mentioned means
that you can
set a mode that allows you to say just
as an example bicep curl
15 pounds up and then lower
automatically
20-25 pounds down and it is incredible
how much you can get done in just a
handful of minutes
when you use this type of technology so
check it out
tri-tonal t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest
home gym for 30 days in your home and if
you don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.comal.com and for a
limited time get 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code
tim21 like i'm ready for
my first drink at checkout that's
www.tonaltonal.com
promo code tim 21 tim21 tonal
be your strongest this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep
my god am i in love with eight sleep
good sleep is the ultimate
game changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle asleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever
why because i'm using a simple device
called the pod
pro cover by eight sleep it's the
easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about
the best tools for sleep enhancing sleep
and ate sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she
loves the heat then we can have our own
bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250
off of the pod pro cover that's a lot
simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim tim eight sleep.com
tim for 200 off your podca cover